at what point does taxation become too  much you were in an area that was 99 tax  you really wanted to live there would  you say oh you have to take 100 times  more I'd say like how reasonable is it  that I can make 99 times more than I can  and at what point does this materially  affect how I live because then I  wouldn't be as wealthy because I don't  have all the money in the world I think  at this point paying 40 versus paying  four percent there's a 36 difference you  know it's a 50 increase in your  take-home it's material in terms of the  number but is it material in terms of  how it affects my life and so the math  that I did on this was am I going to  care if I die worth 10 billion or 15  billion yeah I don't know but I do know  that if I talk to my 85 year old self  he'd be like did you really spend your  entire life where you didn't want to  live because you wanted me to have 5  billion more dollars and then he looks  at me like I'm an idiot